what's with the jeans creepy they're
like what is that movie Jack Nicholson
The Shining The Shining twins
oh right those girls little creepy yeah
that's so crazy
I know I know I like that this lady
looks like you I like your haircut I'm
gonna get that I love the Front's swirl
that's the mom cut for sure good yes has
your expression of my favorite just the
back hair here is really nice I think my
father has this haircut well to me it
just says lady this is Eastern European
tennis player this is Yvonne Lendl right
then Len will have it just do your hair
differently oh yeah whenever I see that
I'm like you're just doing this to
yourself
well she's fully resigned to mom hood
you can see here she's wearing the
hoodie she's still tying in it's weird
doesn't want anyone to know sex this is
a look that says do not come near me
with a penis ever ever ever you know I
figured out why mom's dress frumpy mom
fashions especially if you're a
breastfeeding it's because you have to
access your boobs all the time and
there's not no cute stuff but she's
given up for sure yeah she doesn't need
her yeah boobs to come out anymore no no
no this is almost a dude it's really
close
she might be transitioning you don't
know it I haven't played my transition
took place I'm happy
Jesus Jesus Christ it's really it's
really bad and here's the thing okay
okay you don't have to be a super mom
not saying that and I'm not shitting on
her for like yes you are I'm shitting
here's what I'm shitting on just try all
it is work with what God gave you yeah
you know just try a little man you know
if you want to be a woman if you want to
be heterosexual I don't know is she
why'd you tell everybody about your
dream I dreamt that some other guy
busted nuts in me and I didn't know who
it was and then I got pregnant
again and I was like oh I have to tell
Tom and I'm pregnant again you're fine
jerk it's a dream babe yeah well let's
see what she has to say come true
what does this nice man have at school
that teachers couldn't believe it
primary school we're sitting at the same
table and the occasional cheating no
we're out the dog in the sheet so they
are saying questions what we had before
and the same answers and questions and
sorry oh my god so where is so weird
they never let that guy talk at the
beginning of gentleman who's gonna say
something yeah how do you think his
tennis game is this guy doesn't speak
some parts of the Midwest this is the
norms where do you think this chick guy
what do you think of this nice human
gets their hair cut and what do they say
when they walk in you know what to do
they say it's give me the tennis player
give me the tennis player yeah give me a
cheap e top 5 1989 rock it out
that is a naked 89 90 it's also the
Midwestern there's a lot of ladies in
the Midwestern earth oh yeah there we go
Lana Sam Kinison look-alike women oh no
the last Jesus Christ
I don't know again I'm not knocking her
but all sudden this still crying this
still is more effeminate you know it's
also a little lady die circuit let's you
know what it is I think she was going
for Lady Diana
1980 and you know it looks dated it's a
little dated
it's now it's very dated what I'm saying
is though as far as the stills go this
one is more dude and this one is before
she transitioned this is the woman
because here's here's what would fix
this I'm just saying grow the hair out
just a little more yeah I need to cut my
ears out so I can hear well when you see
my hair fall over my ears cut them out
so that can hear stuff because being a
woman there's not a lot of utility in
our clothing
there's no utility in our hair there's
no utility in wearing makeup right so
when a woman gives up she's going all
function over form function for sure
fuck nothing yeah it's all function at
her at her point I guess a terrible
haircut it's actually the only thing
really she needs to try with just get a
fucking haircut the haircuts bad it's
really bad but in okay she's Ozzy and
you can afford it you got a nice
microwave yeah or have a friend that can
do it for you yeah just grow it out a
little but a lot of Ozzie women I hate
to say this - I've seen a lot of stuff
they you know yeah I got this haircut
the Outback yeah we don't need long hair
yeah this is not an Aussie cut though
yeah you just said it's a Midwestern
time it's a Midwest and it's Australia
because there's a lot of parts there
remote in Australia I like the Midwest
so basically in in remote locations
Indiana and Illinois and Australia yeah
path yeah yeah I is rock hits we were
gonna see this I think crocodile
Dundee's hair was like this - isn't it
Dundee had a nice chasm feathers yeah